[Music]
all right all right
let's hear for the legend Shaquille
O'Neal
why you make that man wrap his [ __ ] up
early that man wasn't done talking
yeah you were in the back he had we gave
we gave plenty of time
can you hear me
turn me up a little turn me all the way
up there we go
he forgot this man was a musical genius
I don't forget that album
Shaq how are you I'm good I'm trying to
be like you
you know it you know they called me in
the nft space right the black garyvee
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Jack it's such an honor to be doing this
with you thank you for doing this
for being here
we should have a small community of 555
within the befriends world let's clap it
up for each other first
so having the goats here as you can
imagine I wanted to be you know when you
weren't here I was giving you some roses
obviously most people think of you as a
goat on the court I especially get
excited when you put out your own top 10
list your own top 20 list I like the way
you play that I always get a kick of
that seeing in my feed but
I I said this and I want to say it to
you
I find you to be a very unusual human
being forget about the level of Charisma
you have and all the things that we all
know I think
entrepreneur creative
incredibly warm-hearted and kind and
giving back obviously an iconic athlete
I think you were a goat human being stop
you're gonna make me cry seriously my
man I love you too Gary
um I'm really really honored to have you
here and really I want to make this
about the goats being able to ask
questions so I'll do a little something
here but goats very honestly I'm I'm
obviously happy to answer anything as
well but I think you know you get more
access to me so if you are incredibly
passionate and have a question for Shaq
in any of the Journeys in the multiple
places he's played the mics are up there
right now you're more than welcome to
start lining up and we will do serious
serious q a while we have him here and
then we'll do a little competing uh
after we're done with this interview so
be before we get into the first
questions
what's Shaq up to right now what is the
big fella excited about
well because of you um
me and my partner we created something
called astrals we're in the nft space
you know I I've learned a lot over the
years
but I remember when I heard you say you
like to surround yourself with smart
people
I've been doing that for years so
you know just continuing to make people
smile
continuing to do the right thing
continuing to be positive
you know this world is getting crazier
and Crazier by the day
so when you see this face hopefully it
makes you laugh
hopefully it inspires you
and hopefully one day you see me whoop
Charles Barkley's ass
what Gary one day I'm gonna just get up
and I'm gonna just smack the [ __ ] out of
trolls just
I don't know where
to win day
Shaq real quick just I'm gonna go very
basketball nerdy just for all the
basketball fans in here uh being a big
one The Season's extremely early
um you have transitioned to be an
incredible commentator along with Sir
Charles
um but it's not just that you guys are
incredibly charismatic and funny and you
do a really incredible job on TV but you
obviously know the game extremely well
and so
we're four seconds in
you know I've watched Sports
aggressively for 40 years so I know how
much changes especially with the NBA
Playoffs all this but any hot takes of
anything you've seen early on that has
caught your attention whether it's the
rookie in Orlando whether it's the way
Golden State's playing or the way the
Sixers and Lakers are playing like
what's the thing that's happened in the
first couple weeks that you're like huh
I would have thought that
Joel embiid will come out with a little
more aggression
because I remember a couple years I
thought I got slighted by Steve Nash
winning the MVP
and I was just pissed the whole summer
and I just wanted to from game one let
everybody know that I'm the real MVP
I got missed over last year and I'm
about to show you six years old and
three so I was kind of disappointing I
just thought that you know he came up
runner up twice to the Joker so I
thought he would be a little bit more
angry and I thought do you think he's
banged up
bro we're all banged up that's an excuse
I don't want to hear that [ __ ] Gary
no excuses you know we like if this was
an easy world everybody be everybody be
billionaires we have a simple game of
knockout coming out and 13 of these
[ __ ] came with casts and [ __ ]
injuries here
like all of a sudden everybody saw at a
cast look at that cast the [ __ ] leg
thing over like everybody's
got plenty excuses here because they
don't want to be exposed in an hour we
will see something he's banged up we're
all banged up but when you talk about
perseverance and you talk about Legacies
just gonna make his legacy much more
like my favorite
my favorite stories are
when guys overcome the impossible the
Michael Jordan Flu Game remember that
game yeah of course where he couldn't
even he couldn't even sit and he needed
oxygen he went out and dominated like
everybody's banged up just gotta you
know suck it up and suck through it and
they're like my motto is if you can walk
on the court then you can play if you're
that banged up don't play
that's a real analogy if you can walk on
it you can play on it
all right look
Shaq's been incredibly gracious with his
incredibly busy schedule so I'm not
going to eat up any more time I want to
give you guys go ahead I don't want this
guy to ask a question because he's been
smiling at me a little too hard
stop [ __ ] smiling you go first you go
we're gonna go there first just ask the
question bro hey hey baby
has a [ __ ] deep sexy voice geez how
are you doing let's uh let's establish
your name and where you're from
Barry from Miami previously Los Angeles
and Toronto I just wanted to say I have
so much respect for you not just the
competitor the businessman but just the
sort of man you've shared so many times
about becoming I'm wondering what advice
you might share with with men about the
kind of man you want to be how do you be
a better man
how to become a better man and what and
what facet
well that's what I'm kind of curious
what you would focus on but I think
emotionally you know showing up in life
with Integrity for family for business
like how do we compete at the highest
level and Achieve at the highest level
but still show up with Integrity like
and love like a kind Warrior like a
v-friend yeah I've always had a switch
I can tell that we're all hustlers in
here
but you got to turn it off
when you come home to your wife and your
kids turn it off
right you don't want to bring that part
into this part
and when I started having children that
helped me because before I had kids I
would just tear my house up ah once I
started having the kids and my first
child was a daughter and she don't care
about any of that now come home and I
see her smile it will make me turn it
off and then not thinking about not
thinking about it boom boom boom and
then the next morning
what had happened was my Bart my my
brain and my battery had recharged now
when I go back to work I can go in full
force so my advice is you have to
modulate right you have to modulate so
the reason why I asked what facet that
you're married you're not married and so
you just have to be able to turn it on
and turn it off and relax sometimes and
remember don't focus on the problem
focus on the solution
like people always say I got a headache
I got a headache I got a headache as
soon as I say I need some [ __ ]
aspirin the headache goes away so think
about the problem and then immediately
start thinking about the solution thank
you very much and never stop asking
Chuck about the women of San Antonio I
love that
we're not allowed to do that anymore
let's keep this going I want to get as
many
Sam I'm from Phoenix
yes go Sons um got a little testy there
last night
yes yeah absolutely really physical
um
just want to say Jack I love you love
that you've always just been yourself
from day one uh Gary love you man know
her I stand with you uh Shaq I just want
to briefly share uh my favorite Shack
moment of all time because you are
everywhere
all the time it seems like uh but do you
remember when you were on SNL and your
name was Bernard and uh your dad was
Tracy Morgan
and he was like
uh get your ass over here I'm gonna
spank your butt Bernard would you like
to reenact that scene yes yes
let's go
unbelievable you're the [ __ ] best
you're the [ __ ] best
all right next question before I get my
ass back
all right so Tracy was sitting down
[Laughter]
this is unbelievable
this this was shot on SNL about 20 years
ago I don't want you I don't want you to
think this is some new [ __ ] all right
all right Bernard get your ass over here
on both spank your butt
[Laughter]
how many times I gotta tell you get here
on time boy
let's clap that up
foreign
that's awesome
don't ever do that again to not have
that on the bingo card I will kill you
what's up Shaq Big Aristotle what's up
brother my name is Brian I'm from New
York
um so I started a meal prep company in
2015. did unbelievably well and January
of 2020 I was diagnosed with brain
cancer
in March the world shut down with covet
so business was going very well and a
lot of the locations that I dropped off
at because we delivered to houses and
gyms they shut down permanently
now I opened up a brick and mortar
a lot of good things going for me right
now I've kind of overloaded my plate I
have to deal with the casino co-packing
for them a nationwide company co-packing
for them
um but right now I have my hands in so
many different pots I don't know what
the [ __ ] to do it's just I kind of
loaded my plate with so much [ __ ] that I
need help
um more so capital for hiring an
operating manager but I'm kind of you
know lack of better terms lost in the
sauce here
what would your advice be get help I'm
trying to you want to help no seriously
get help you know Eisenhower said the
greatest leaders are the ones that hire
people that are smarter
got to get help can't you can't be
everywhere at once so get help are you
did you did I I apologize did you say
you need you're looking for Capital
look at all that like do if I have let's
say I get a half million dollars well do
I do 250 and Equipment this will be good
answer for everyone the first place you
deploy Capital when you're growing is to
hire someone to do the [ __ ] that you
know has to get done that you like the
least
right because the key this is a very
important Insight your energy is what
you need to protect
and when you're doing [ __ ] that you
don't want to be doing but you know you
have to and we all do that in many
facets it's draining you
you might even be good at it there's
things that I'm good at that I hire for
early on because I know it's a drainage
I don't love it I don't wake up on
Wednesday and say oh I can't wait for
these three hours so where you deploy
that capital is the things that are
taking up your time every single day and
every week that you don't like what if
you can't afford that help that you hire
well then you're out of business
right like like the thing that people
forget about businesses it's not
supposed to always be easy like right
now everyone's about to go out of
business because For the first time in a
decade people are not going to be able
to raise money
and people are just going to go out of
business so what you start doing is
actually running a profitable business
and you start scrapping every company
I've ever started you start with
youngsters that you kind of co-train you
might be able not hired the 150 000
person to do the thing that you do but
you might be able to hire the 22 year
old you for 14 an hour who wants to get
taught and you work with her or him for
six seven nine months alongside and then
you slide it off
and it'll be less stressful for you if
you start focusing on the solution
Andy was an intern
for jab jab jab Jab
was an intern
for jab jab jab right hook the book
and I didn't want to pay him but my
lawyer said we'd get sued
right they're out there
by the way they're about to be really
out there
and they just he said something that was
very interesting he said even if I had
capital I don't know what to do with it
ask
like when I don't know [ __ ] I ask
hey man how'd you get this
like I've met the CEO of this I'm like
hey what is this how is it like I've
seen it but how boom you ask questions
real quick because I know a lot of you
in this room because I'm gonna keep
going I want to get this many
this goes back to how I started this
session if you're sitting right now and
you feel like you have actual advice
because you've actually done it right
Make Some Noise right now if you feel
like that way that's it you've got seven
people Gonna Roll Up on you and give you
the answer all right thank you remember
good help bro
Jack big fan I'm Sean from Arizona
Die Hard lifelong Suns fan
uh and as a Die Hard there's a lot of my
Die Hard friends a debate trading for
uno7
being a mistake
but I want to tell you why I always
defend that it was the right trade
what Gary talked about at the beginning
the kindness that you deploy the the
things that you've created outside of
your career as an NBA player
the stat line
that always gets me to stand to stand up
and say no trading for Shaq was the
right move
might surprise you it wasn't your free
throw percentage
I don't get sensitive was it I'm sorry
there was something in the contract I
don't know if you read it when you kind
of signed when you came in free throws
out you had to leave you have to leave
the building it was great seeing you a
lot of jokes
but for real the stat line of is you the
amount of times you stood on some
sketchy street corners in Phoenix
handing out yourself tickets to the
Sun's Game to fans representing my city
representing my team
my question is what role has kindness
played in building your success
my mother taught me a long time ago
cost you nothing to be nice
when I first became
Shaq 18 19 years old I was arrogant
my mother and my father are people you
don't talk back to my father said be
careful who you step on
on your way to success
and my mother would say who the hell are
you oh that ended my arrogance she said
because you're starting to get all this
stuff doesn't make you better than my
man up there sitting next to her son
doesn't make me better than this guy
with the hat y'all stay ahead you know
so and then my favorite word always be
humble
so with me what you see is what you get
I don't like you know I do a lot of
random acts of kindness I don't like
bragging about it because that's not
what I'm about yeah like I just like
making people happy the thing that I
wish I had the answer for
homelessness homelessness hurts my heart
the other day where were we the other
day we were in some City the other day
and we saw a guy eating dirt
where Baltimore yeah we're in Baltimore
and we came under the bridge and the guy
was eating dirt
and then I just went out like I wanted
to just you know so I'm always remain
humble remain kind are those soft skills
you look for in businesses you invest in
or Partners you take on like is that an
important trait uh that you look to I
have to believe in the product
and I never look at the monetary aspect
of it
just have to believe if I believe and I
could believe it's something that's I
mean it's going to you know be good for
the people
are usually invest nope thank you I'm
surprised to hear that you were and I
better not see you in the parking lot
knock your ass out I'm surprised I'm
surprised say something now free throw
Joke Man
I'm surprised you were you know you felt
that you were so uh
like cocky and over I was because in
Stanley Roberts creates some humility
when you first got to LSU yeah but from
9-15
I was terrible you're terrible you're
never going to make it you suck
six nine you can't dump join the Army
like your father you're never gonna make
you're never gonna make it and I'm a
hustler you know
keep working no matter what they say
whoever they may be keep working so
finally when I get the status as a
number one player it was like my way of
saying [ __ ] you yes so but then I would
I would I would just do crazy stuff with
my mom she didn't like it so she said
you know what just stay humble yes sir
hey my name is Gerard I'm from Detroit
what's up Shaq what's up brother good to
see you again I have two questions first
questions for both of you guys is real
quick
um so last year at the end of last year
I realized like money's not really going
to change me like I'm still staying
where I'm at but I have realized that
money has money has changed it can make
relationships a little bit different for
like your close close friends like your
close family and friends do you have any
advice like practical advice that you
can deal with money with like your inner
circle because I heard like some that
like you know never lend it out don't
ask for money back or
I have a lot of friends
and when I first got made big time I
said you've been down with me I'm down
with you what do you want to do
and they give me an idea we create an
LLC
you work for me now I'm just gonna give
you money right
you know like okay you want to start a
record label it's like like let's do it
you want to do this you want to do that
so you know if you if they're your
close-knit group and you don't want to
give it to them I want you like I said
like I told the other guy get help use
them as your helper and create something
bigger but I would say create an LLC put
them on payroll and get some of that
money back like you just you're right
because they do change
trust me they change but you know you
don't want to get rid of them because
they've been there with you let's just
say like hey you're my guy let's just
grow together
yeah for me it was
for the Inner Circle yeah it was
if I was giving money I was giving money
so not least you know what I mean yeah
like a couple people in my life tried to
say I'll pay you back my brain didn't
even accept it yeah you know if this was
somebody I was close to and I could
afford it I would you have to be
comfortable also saying no
I was accountable to me I wasn't going
to judge them I knew [ __ ] could change
and you know things would change for me
in the future I always felt that I could
make more in the future but if I wanted
to give because they were close to me I
gave and it was more about me not
creating resentment towards them than
worrying about their actions if I gave I
gave and if I didn't I didn't but if I
gave I didn't create resentment or
expectation of them and then Just Having
the courage to say no basically yeah
you're gonna have to have the in my
framework you had to have the courage to
say no
um which you know
it took me a long time to get good at
yes even back then I'm sure if I think
back some of it was sloppy some of it
was avoidance slippery on the court you
know but yeah you've got like the best
case scenario was having the capacity to
say no but when you say yes
understanding that that does not come
with it like you're give you're giving
yeah
yeah and then last question so Shaq I'm
actually right now making uh trying to
make one of the biggest nft projects
ever like I'm really really ambition
project and just being honest
straightforward I want to actually
sponsor you as like the first athlete of
my nft project is actually a beer pong
project and it's going to be in a
Midwest location I got six facilities
it's gonna be a Friday Saturday and
Sunday in August and um obviously your
A-Plus celebrity and that's what helped
but the thing is what I'm noticed my
first phase is I have to work with nil
and college students and I'm starting to
realize when you're talking to college
students what they want is that dollar
they don't care about ethereum they
don't care about an nft they don't care
about Bitcoin and all that type of stuff
and um it's a little bit tough trying to
explain to them what a digital asset is
and all that type of things so just
having
um you know somebody who is at that type
of level if you'll be interested and um
you know we can sponsor you just like an
icy hot you know what I mean
um which would be interesting my
partner's right there under you with the
blue hat talk to him about that sounds
good thank you thank you keep it going
Big Fish Benny Pittsburgh PA
how are you doing Shaq I like you
brother what's up thanks man you know my
favorite part about Pittsburgh is that
it doesn't have a basketball team
well I'm like I'm a Cavs fan I was
actually born in Canton Ohio grew up
with LeBron up the road a little bit so
I love the days in Cleveland like the
six months I think that you're in there
but anyway
my buddy
Vinnie who did these awesome gift goat
shoes for me made a painting I don't
know if you guys saw it yet it was the
back yeah and we only have one it's
custom right and I want to give it to
one of you too
he mentioned free throws it'd be cool to
have a free throw contest between the
two of you to get the painting okay
because it's a really cool it's a really
cool no just between retired it's a
retired all right well whatever again I
don't want to lose the shack and free
then figure out
Gary okay don't [ __ ] touch me all
right all right hey hey Gary just figure
out who gets it I want to go to YouTube
figure auction it for Charity My
question is about business and I love
the gentleman's question about how to
find your right hand man I can help you
with that because you will have a lot
more fun in life
when you go to start businesses and you
do a lot of philanthropy philanthropy
how do you decide
um what philanthropic projects to do how
do you incorporate it with business what
are the goals how how do you how do you
mix all that together I really would
love to know more because I'm I've
already built one business and I'm
getting ready to build a media company
and I really want to start from the
beginning with with philanthropy I deal
with
things that are close to my heart
always tell the three stories one story
is
a father got some extra cash
came home big man that was my nickname
it was big man let's go get something to
eat so we go to White Castle you ever
heard of White Castle yeah yeah I'm
gonna go to White Castle I get six
double cheese it gets six double cheese
we couldn't finish them
on the way back we see a guy that has a
sign
homeless guy will work for food my
father pulls over and find out the guy
was in the military on hard times and I
kind of asked I didn't understand I said
why'd you give him my food and he said
if you could ever help those in need
make sure you you take care of them so I
do a lot with the homeless initiative
I do a lot with the children uh it's an
alarming stat that 15 million kids a
year will wake up on Christians and not
receive one single toy so I do an event
that's called Shack a close and that's
just close to my heart and then you know
when I was young my father was a drill
sergeant he would uh get all the troops
and they would get all their all their
clothes he'd come early Saturday morning
go go to get their clothes put them in
boxes and we take them to the Salvation
Army and you know they're saying another
man's trash is another man's treasure
like when we would take those old army
clothes to the people at Salvation or
they would be so I do a lot with the
Salvation Army so how do you how do you
how do you decide though like what
percentage of Revenue or whatever I feel
like yeah that's an objective call okay
it's a great question that's a great
question I mean but I do sorry but I do
real [ __ ] I'm gonna do one two thousand
dollars I'll do 50 and up like I don't
here's a thousand no I do 50 100 200 a
million right no comma
this means a juggernaut right like and I
think you know uh I'm I'm a well member
of Charity water so anytime anybody here
donates ten dollars to charity water all
the money goes to actually building
wells in Africa over a billion people
now down to 850 850 million people don't
have access to clean water back to
gratitude like clean [ __ ] water so
what happened for me a human being
changed the course for me it was about
Scott and his passion to get it done and
he said one thing in the first time we
sat down that changed the way I did
everything he's like Gary you're a good
dude and you're probably thinking the
way we all grew up you're gonna make it
and then you're gonna give it away he's
like why not now
right so like most of us haven't gotten
to the place we have in our mind to when
we're going to give but and obviously
this man has created a lot of
opportunity and wealth creation for
himself his family and the things he's
passionate about but there's not a
person in here who can't give 500 bucks
or a thousand it matters and so and
you're you're deciding how much is very
personal it's extremely personal and it
will continue to be personal some years
are better than others sometimes you
need to take care of your family instead
of something you're altruistic about and
so that's very personal
and I'm I'm impressed by one person in
here
that's just dad and his son I love it
and let me tell you why when I was young
my father used to bring me to events
like this and I'm sitting there and I
don't never know what's going on but I
could tell a little man is paying
attention I already have 12
yeah I could tell he's paying attention
to these stuff are you scared to tell
the big fella he was wrong
so he's sitting here he's soaking all
his knowledge up so you know when I
became the shack I already had so much
knowledge that like yeah I get it I'm
not sure he's paying attention he
probably is not only that to Dad in
certain points when we've been talking
was whispering on the things that he
thought was illegal so little man make
sure you always listen to your mommy and
daddy
no seriously make sure you always listen
to your mom and dad I'm proud of you for
being here
nice to see you Mr Grayson yes that's
impressive let's go LSU
that's the flashbacks my dad used to
bring me it up I'm like what the [ __ ] am
I doing here but then when I got older
I'm like oh I remember this and boom bam
so make sure you listen to your dad all
right I'm Ross I went to LSU and also a
member of a D9 fraternity go mob
um Shaq I'm so thankful for you and the
impact you've made on my alma mater and
just the D9 Community as a whole
um you are an icon and have done so much
Superstar on and off the court it's
something that's been mentioned a lot is
what everybody admires so much about you
is your kindness and the things the
videos that impressed me are the ones
hearing about you getting your shoes in
Walmart because you wanted everybody to
be able to afford them you buy in
people's groceries laptops whatever it's
just the moments with individual people
where you're showing that kindness the
care you've got a huge heart and you
really impress me man
um what really instilled that in you
what were the moments the people what
was that shift for you to be the person
that you are today
I just realized I'm lucky
I mean I yeah it was a great basketball
player but I'm lucky that they pay us a
lot of money
I'm lucky so you know if I can help
those in need it was the way I was
raised just the right thing to do it's
never planned out I just it just hits me
like my favorite store to go to is Best
Buy and I'm always looking for the moms
moms and the kids and moms have to be
moms have to take everything I just wait
for them to price price check how much
1500 no how much is this one now now I
know I got one
so I talked to the kid be like go ask
your mom can you take a computer from a
stranger
be like what be like listen I want to
give you this but I don't want you
taking stuff from people so go ask your
Mom is it okay so the moms will turn
around and see me because it's just the
right thing to do like 1500 is a lot to
Mom but not really a lot to me it's not
well I'm gonna do this in postal code
for hours just it hits me it's the right
thing to do if I could help somebody
save 1500 but get the computer that they
really want that's what it's all about
and again I I look I'm one of the
luckiest guys in the world like I
remember the first time I rode on the
plane with garyvee a lot of guys see
garyvee but you don't get to ride on the
plane from Atlanta to Paris and pick his
brain for nine [ __ ] hours yeah and he
doesn't stop talking and he didn't go to
sleep
so I'm just asking questions so I'm look
I'm just one of the luckiest guys in the
world
thank you so is that pretty natural for
you just like that feeling of being
lucky and blessed no it's because I've
been because I've been in both worlds
I've been in a world where you're
nothing
you stink you suck and then I've been in
a world where oh my God it's you you so
you know like like when I was in high
school I was a man but he talked about
Stanley Roberts when I got to college I
realized you're not that [ __ ] good
and then you have to rise back to the
top now I'm the number one college
player when I got to the NBA I realized
hey you're not the man so when you're
not the man you can't be acting like
your other man you have to you know calm
down wait your turn but again look I
just like I I like making people smile
you know they always say when when it's
all said and done what do you want to be
remembered for I don't care about how
much money I make how many companies on
I want people to say Shaq was a nice guy
[Music]
thank you let's keep it going
hey Shaq nice jacket yeah man uh Chris
from Jersey City okay
my question is what what I'm inspired
[ __ ] I'm nervous
um I'm inspired by you uh based on your
ability to redefine who you are you've
been you've been labeled you know NBA's
player and and now you're you're this DJ
business Mogul philanthropist
um my question is an advice question so
I just got the job of my dreams
but I feel like an imposter and so when
you walk into these new situations and
you're trying to reinvent yourself from
the label you have to a new label how do
you think through uh you know dealing
with that situation and and the Imposter
syndrome that comes with that
so when you
invited into a new area you're invited
there because you're good right but you
feel like an imposter and you should
you're just getting it so listen
learn and then add a little bit of your
own flavor that's it
listen
to the guy that's been working there 10
years see how it did words learn okay I
thought you do it this way and then add
a bit of your own flavor you're there
for a reason it hired you for a reason
because you are the man so listen learn
and add your own flavor that's all I
could like like you know when I when I
step into a new thing I don't come in
like I know it all I listen learn and
then just add a little bit of your own
flavor and you'll be fine and remember
you got the job could have been a
hundred other thousand people that got
the job but they [ __ ] hired you so
you're the man and own it and know it
an important thing to jump in on for
everybody real quick if you're paying
attention I'm just as an observation
that I hope brings value if you're
listening I one thing I I've always
liked about
Shaq's points of view and and I really
associate with them because
I think it's how I think about things
there's incredible levels of simplicity
in what we're talking about here it's
the discipline to get it done that
people are struggling with not the
insights to how to do it
everybody here has heard the ways to do
it you can Google it you can literally
[ __ ] Google it this is why I talk so
much about patience or turning out the
noise whether it's high or low
because the reality is is that people
are struggling with the execution of
from an emotional standpoint of having
the perseverance the discipline and most
of all the patience
because so many people have so much
attachment to the success of
they're so attached to the success of
that they want it to happen faster so
they get that feeling
when you think about someone who's
accomplished what he has
to be so detached from all those
accolades to only want to be attached to
the Simplicity of he was a nice guy
that's why he's able to do all those
things and this is the framework
that you have to get there and a lot of
it is think about the sergeant the mom
the people along the way we are so
affected by the people that we spent
time with this has so much to do about
my ambition with what we're trying to do
I genuinely feel a lot of people here
will be affected by the people in here
more than by me more than by this hour
and you should fight for the people that
have that conversation and that energy
to be the people that are closest to you
let's keep it going hi my name is shiv
I'm in San Diego California and my
question is I run a digital marketing
agency and as I've kind of achieved a
certain level of success I'm always kind
of cognizant of not creating a situation
where I'm surrounded by yes men with the
people who work for me obviously you two
are very very big kind of notable people
in the space and I just wonder how you
Shack create an environment where people
don't just want to agree with you every
second of every moment of every day
because your Shack instead of saying hey
Shaq that business idea is really dumb
right and that's really stupid and
having that that friction and not just
agreeing because they're afraid of their
job or they have to say yes to stay
around you
I have about
20 people that work for me
and we argue all the time because
they're not Yes Men
the thing that keeps us together is we
never disrespect each other
again all the people that are with me
they're smarter than me I know that but
every now and then I like to know we
should do this and I'll be like no
that's stupid and we argue what that
gives this point I give my point okay
you're right
same thing with me and Kobe we argued
all the time but we never disrespected
each other that's why we're able to win
three championships in a row so you
never won a yes guy you want somebody
that's going to give you their honest
opinion and if you do it like I do it I
always got smart guys around me right
right I'm the dumbest guy in my gang and
I love it so when we we you know have
these conversations
it's always good and it's always best
out for me like my best friend Brian we
we were arguing about is the earth flat
or is it round
you know that thing it's it's a triangle
the fact that you're even asking the
question has already solved the issue
anybody anybody who's scared to have yes
men and women around them is not going
to have yes and Men Women around them
it's people who can't see it it's a
silent poison right I appreciate it
thank you and I have one last question
I'm giving away this jacket to one of
the gift goats here I know we're not
supposed to do signatures but because
it's given away is there a way you both
can sign this jacket if you hit a
three-pointer oh
all right there we go all right come on
go appreciate it give me we'll give you
three chances but if you miss we're not
signing [ __ ]
my man while we get him set up what's
good guys my name is direct coming from
L.A
and my question is with all the success
that you guys both have had how do you
deal with failures and how do you
prevent the fear of failure from
stopping you from executing something
new well I never think about failure and
keep in mind
before you succeed you must first learn
to fail
but you never want to keep making the
same mistake twice
so whatever you did and you failed
delete that [ __ ] control write all
delete never do it again
and then making the game for yourself
I'm gonna try it this way
I'm gonna try it this way it's only
gonna make you stronger disappointment
will only make you stronger it's a very
very small percentage that gets it right
the first time the rest of us
we have to fail we have to argue we have
to fight we have to do this we have to
do that
but I never think about failing never
ever always think about the positive
outcome and then sometimes when reality
kicks in Failure happens and then you
just adjust
life is about adjusting when I'm coming
here I live 45 minutes away 75 North
it's a traffic jam am I going to sit in
a traffic jam no Gary's gonna be pissed
if I'm late let me make it right here
let me make a left here you have to
adjust in life like when we sit down and
dream and think about things we always
think think how perfect they could be
but again when reality kicks in
the quick you can adjust
the better you'll become in business
for for me the feeling failure
fearing it is 100 predicated on you
valuing the crowd's opinion
100 because if you love failing the way
I do it's an indicator that you're
challenging yourself
and you have the humility to know that
you're going to lose a ton
you know I I this is my number one thing
like the jet like athlete in the context
if this man factored in what the crowd
was doing while he was performing it's
inconceivable to achieve
everybody here who fears failing is
fearing it to someone
right usually a parent right or a spouse
or things that nature so understanding
that the fear is only based on that once
you calibrate that then you start loving
fear get your ass back down here all
right let's do it let's let's see the
[ __ ] let's chop it up here we go don't
be scared
this is gonna be ugly
anybody wants some side action
you might want to take that jacket off
take the jacket off
no no no
NBA three-pointer come on shiv
I don't think he's gonna make this shot
NBA three-pointer come on
two to one two to one no pressure no
pressure
how much
in
here we go
no
oh
full stack right
full stack
s
[Applause]
yep Gary Gonna Make It Rain yep yep yep
Easy Money Baby
hey can we start betting V for hey can
we start be friend twos all right here
we go let's keep it going
position wearing number 34 she'll kill
body
sorry I gotta do that my name is Mikey
um born and raised in La huge fan of
yours follow you your whole championship
ring there in LA I'm living in Vegas now
actually an acquaintance and worked with
Perry
your your manager but my question for
you is I wanna I wanna for both of you
is a basketball question
so what's going on with Russ why isn't
he being like he was before like I feel
bad for us
and I'm a speculate because I haven't
talked to him about it but yeah I've
never
played in my hometown and people booed
me
I never played on a team where everybody
said it's your fault
never played on a team where I feel like
they don't want me
and mentally that has to be tough on a
person like I can remember him talking
about
his wife and kids sitting in the stand
and everybody just boom boom boom boom
boom to try to play and think about that
it has to be difficult
well he probably would he probably needs
a fresh start
so I can't answer that question because
I've I've never had that problem but I
think if I was to play in LA and they
would boo me it would probably get to me
if I was to go home to New Jersey and
play in the Meadowlands and playing in
Madison Square Garden and you know
people boom me it would probably hurt so
I'm sure he's going through a lot so I'm
not going to jump on the kill Russ
bandwagon but
think about that the other day like it
just it has to be a lot and and usually
for us when things are going good we
don't have to worry about any of that
come play go home now
what's that guy saying to my wife oh I
missed a shot he's making a face like it
you know it has to be overwhelming it's
funny you brought that up I did a
podcast yesterday hasn't come out yet
where I just lost my mind on this issue
I actually think
this rough situation is going to be
looked back on 15 years from now because
I think it's a next level of the things
I hate the most in society I think
there's a lot of young kids that think
it's just cool to make fun of Russ and
the behavior and the amplification of it
is the most extreme thing I've seen in
sports there's been a lot of stuff but
it's it's literally disgusting that
people are we've taken the sense of
tearing someone else down to make
yourself feel better I think the world
is anxious I think there's a lot of
unhappiness and it's it's become a thing
and people are doing [ __ ] that they
don't even fully believe in because
they're just stuck in [ __ ] high
school in their brain and I think some
of the pundits on TV are giving a lot of
gas to it and I think it's a it's a real
[ __ ] problem and it's really too bad
and I I Echo your feelings I'm I've
never had any attachment to Russ I don't
have his rookie cards I'm not a thunder
or other teams that he's played on fan
I've had nothing kind of like any reason
to be an over fan I don't know if I've I
I the whole thing has actually actually
bothered me and I think it's an
indicator
unfortunately that things are going to
get worse with the fan player relations
because it's totally [ __ ] up
unacceptable it's one thing to be in a
rivalry a Clippers fan being like uh but
like where this is gone is really just
[ __ ] horseshit yeah it's totally
disgusting that's why I just wanted to
get the State of the Union form from you
guys on what that is all about because
it's [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up it's
[ __ ] up we're gonna keep this moving I
want to get this many people as possible
ah Gary
I love you guys honestly I'm so grateful
that you guys are here my name is
Jonathan from defense Canada Toronto you
got you two are the goats in like
everything that you do my question is
what attributes are the most important
to get to that level of greatness and
how do you cultivate that
check
I try to
help other people become great
whether I'm great or not
mentally always thought I was great
to mentally you have to say I'm great
no matter what so but I try to spread
joy to other people
hey how you doing whether it's a
handshake a picture piece of advice
you know kind of kind of based off the
John Wooden basketball Theory
the the true definition of a great
player is one that makes other people
great
right so I just try to instill greatness
into other people like I don't again how
much money he makes how many companies
on doesn't matter who cares
how can I help you sir how can I help
you ma'am how can I help you little kid
right because it was people like this
that made me who I am today
like I would ask questions I would see
other inspiring stories I would do this
I was a copycat oh I want to do that I
want to be like this oh Gary's of the
nfts hey Brian what's this nft thing
about yeah we should start a company so
like you know I'm always inspired by
people that are smarter than me that are
greater than me but remember we're all
great
we're all great and if you believe
you're great you'll be the greatest
thing since sliced bread
for me when you asked a question what
came to mind is
and I spend a lot
eight Place trophies is no one's going
to be great at anything if they're not
competitive and the fact that Society
decided to kind of manipulate being
competitive potentially viewed as a
negative is a real [ __ ] problem in my
opinion that's just something I'm very
passionate about number two I think the
other thing that almost everyone
struggles with on their path to
Greatness is 100 accountability it is
staggering to me how obsessed people are
with pointing fingers and not thumbs it
is scary to watch people genuinely
believe it's everyone's fault but
themselves in a world where you can do
anything you want you can adjust
um and then and then the third one is
patience like I'm just shocked how
people talk about greatness or people
say [ __ ] that is like one percent life
right the average income in the U like
the one percent earners in America
start at about 440 000 a year if you
make 440 000 a year you are now in the
one percent earners in America one of
the richest countries in the world but
people talk [ __ ] like I'm gonna make a
million bucks
acting like they don't realize that's a
one percent thing and then aren't
willing to eat one percent [ __ ]
everybody like the [ __ ] entitlement
the subconscious entitlement of human
beings is fascinating and that's why
when I see parenting Dynamics what I
think about is
are we teaching our kids that life is
real and let them lose like back to the
question earlier about the fear of
losing I think one of the most important
things a parent can do is put their
child in as many positions as possible
to lose
what we know what we know is that over
the last 30 years of modern parenting it
went reverse
we [ __ ] did everything we could to
not make them lose and now we're
wondering why they're struggling out
there because they're scared shitless of
everything because they never tasted
[ __ ] the blood of [ __ ] losing
so patience matters if you want to be
[ __ ] goat and great and do all this
[ __ ] that I see everyone saying that
they're going to do in the Discord well
you gotta to do that over a long period
of time nothing happens over [ __ ]
night and you're gonna have to do it by
being 100 accountable because if it's
your this person's fault or that's
person's fault you [ __ ] suck
thank you thank you so much I love you
guys
hey Shaq hey Gary I'm Mike from Israel
shalom
I was sitting in my shack a couple of
weeks ago thinking about you all right
now the truth is I really I haven't
asked but I wanted to say thank you
first uh honestly thank you to Gary
putting this together but I recently saw
a video shack are you saying uh that
you'd like to go into stores and buy
things for people who can't afford Etc
and I was in Walmart earlier buying some
stuff for my kids and there was a mother
in front of me who put something back
right there at the register and I said
if I'm gonna go see Shaq and I'm gonna
feature to myself so thank you thank you
inspire me
um when uh when V friends started so
Mikey and I we had the privilege of
putting together a group of about 50 of
our wonderful good friends together uh
and we bought a number of tokens
together as the pastor partners and
thanks guys and um we're gonna be
building a couple of different uh
projects together one of them we've
thought of is to build a shark tank Lake
Project to help out other v-friend
owners and other goats to to help with
you know we have lots of guys who have
plenty of uh experience in business who
can put in resources and energy to help
out people to build businesses
um and we were thinking about calling it
The the goat tank
um would you let us call it the goat
Shack
that's gonna cost you 600 million
dollars over two years
excellent talk to the guy with the blue
hat would you join us and
and talk to him will do I appreciate it
in the spirit of count of competition
who's thrown down more Shaq you Duncan
uh on the court or Gary You Dropped In
f-bombs Gary
thank you down a rim in New Jersey I'll
never forget that listen we've got 10
minutes before the thing we got a lot of
people in line we're going to try to
convert into rapid fire Shaq and I will
try to keep it tight because I'd love to
sneak us in so let's keep it going we're
gonna go fast please everyone all right
my name is Mike haga from Munich Bavaria
um Gary thank you for answering the
questions in my book thank you
um
we have the possibility to pick the
brains of two of the of the biggest
marketing Geniuses here
um how would you Market a new beer brand
that is targeted to an nft audience I
made a it's called 10 Apes it's a board
beer I'm using my 10 board Apes for the
10 different beers how would you Market
that the two marketing geniuses
well my my marketing strategy always
involves humor
yeah that's good I'm a comedian you guys
work hard all day
stress whatever when you come home you
want to crack opening a beer you want to
watch a great game you want to watch
your show whatever it is my favorite
show is Blacklist
and when you see my face I want to be
the guy to make you laugh so whatever
the product is I don't know what the
product is but it would have to have
some type of humor in it cool cool I can
do that everyone's marketing strategies
in this room
has to be fully predicated on putting
out as much creative to as smaller group
of people as they can afford in
resources in their money and their time
and say it's slow again because this
matters to everybody the tick
tockification of all social media
is now happened and has changed
everything we grew up with the last 15
years when social media is growing in
importance
putting out as much content as possible
that isn't trying to reach everyone but
is trying to reach small specific groups
thus rendering you being very specific
in what you're putting out
is now the way to win in marketing used
to be one big commercial with a [ __ ]
tagline to try to reach all of you
because it was this now it's this from
the bottom and so what you need to do is
create 50 to 100 different consumer
segmentations for your beer 21 to 25
year olds in Mexico 30 to 35 year old
moms like psychographic demographic uh
Financial 50 to 100 30 to 40 cohorts
producing one to two pieces of content
per cohort across the 7 to 12 social
networks that matter when something goes
viral because that's what happens now
you put paid media behind the virality
to amplify it because the algo proved
that it's working
that's what you should do very helpful
thank you cool we're going to keep going
may I leave two hands with you
we'll get them we'll get them hey I'm
Michael from Atlanta uh Shaq I've always
been a big fan ever since I was a little
boy and uh friends with Cheryl and Ernie
and every year I see you on the
Christmas party list and I was hoping
always running Jesus it's a pleasure uh
to meet you in person this question is
for both of you and this goes back to
what Gary was just saying about the
um the kind of the entitlement and the
finger-pointing culture I started my
business 20 years ago when I was 17. as
I get older everyone now is younger than
me as I as I continue to age that worked
for me and this this this younger
generation is not the grinding you know
working hard it's doing less and
pointing fingers my question to you is
is what we struggle with every day and
our business is how do you create the
culture of accountability
I don't have any younger people working
for me so I don't know because as as a
leader I don't put up with that
at all
so
all the guys that's working for me are
my age who grew up together we've been
together 20 years so
I wish I could answer that I'll jump in
I have a thousand employees under the
age of 25.
um I go back to accountability yeah I I
have unlimited people I'm looking at
many people right now under 30 who work
their face off yeah and they work their
face off because they trust me because
we have actual conversation how many
employees do you have 40 40 yeah I'm
gonna throw you out the [ __ ] window
let me explain why okay you need to have
real one-on-one conversations with these
people and ask them what drives them
you should have absolutely no problem on
this instead of taking an ideological
point of view which you earned when I
heard 17 20 you [ __ ] grind it but
don't turn into that person you know
what I'm talking about when my day or
you [ __ ] like you're 37 you're not
137. 1 37 PM big shout out anyway so
so
what you need to do is have the humility
to be an accountable leader and try to
figure out what each one of them
ticks with
when you talk to them after 15 minutes
each you may have a read of like two of
them are like completely full of [ __ ]
that's great you can fire but you're
gonna find that for 12 of them the fact
that you even give a [ __ ] to care about
what they care about versus what you
care about them achieving for you
changes [ __ ] everything the second
you realize you work for those 40 people
they don't work for you watch what the
[ __ ] happens with this problem yeah
cool thank you let's keep it going hi uh
my name is Harry I'm from the UK thank
you guys for flying me out
um get the bike closer to you brother
Shaq a question for you
um when people Grill you about your free
throw percentage how much does it
actually get to you and how much did it
get you in your playing career
my mother told me one day when I was
pissed
she said
even when being criticized
there's some truth in criticism
not a good free throw shoot I can't get
mad at that that's a fact right 53 make
one miss one that doesn't bother me it's
a fact
but I overcame that by
saying okay I'm gonna be so dominant and
I'm still gonna win the Championships
and I'm still gonna do this and I'm
still gonna make your favorite player
quit
and it kind of offsets that I was a
terrible free throw shooter because even
though I was a terrible Fredo shooter I
like to assume I was one of the most
dominant big men ever so it's funny I
like to laugh and it's true like you
can't be can't be mad at a true
statement
was it more of a case of focus on your
strengths instead of getting caught up
in your
weaknesses I can't hear you was it more
of a case of uh focusing on your
strengths instead of getting caught up
in your mouth yeah he was like [ __ ]
missing free throws I'm gonna take a
[ __ ] on Chris Dudley exactly
that's what's up
we were pissed
me and mooser Nick fans we were upset
about that one go ahead that's going
viral with the [ __ ] you just said
uh Kilted Dragon chair and I'm from
Charlotte thank you for being here and
Gary thank you and um I just want to say
Shaq that you're epic giver and uh of
course Gary gives away everything and I
think it's amazing and to be early in
nfts like we all are and um I did notice
that you have a mutant ape but you did
not get a board ape so you probably
missed out on this so uh this is my gift
to you thank you for being here and
appreciate it that's awesome thank you
it's a man with the blue hat
it's very nice appreciate you I'm gonna
keep going fast Shaq's gonna hang out as
we transition to this thing a little bit
so some of you will be able to say
what's up real quick hi guys I'm Bruce
from Germany and having observed YouTube
from afar and also having observed you
to just now when answering questions
I noticed that both of you uh guys who
learn predominantly from other people
around you so my question to both of you
is Shaq what did you learn from garyvee
and Gary what did you learn from Shaq I
learned a lot when he listens he's a
very
the reason why I started listening to
Gary
is because he speaks my language
I can't relate to the Harvard
Facebook suit guys I can't
like I heard of garyvee and you know we
the first time we met we were with the
TNT executives
and I sat up front
I didn't say anything to Gary but as he
was talking because they were like gave
me garyvee garyvee motivational speaker
boom boom but when he came on dressed
like that I was like who the [ __ ] is
this guy but then when he started
talking I was like he speaks my language
so I slid up to the front it was me him
Conan and Brian and then I started
picking his brain and ever since I met
him because he's a real guy he says it
like he means it I started follow him
and then he
whenever I look and I see something
you know and he he has the ability to
see things before that happened he was
one of the first guys to talk about the
nft thing and I didn't really know much
about it but I know who did my best
friend Brian bloody who's sitting right
there I said hey I'm a singing this
garyvee thing tell me what so Gary spoke
in a language that he understood and
Brian speaks a little money oh it's this
digitized for the band but a band you
own it on it okay well let's set
something up let's do it so I learned a
lot from him uh I love him because he's
real and you know he speaks my language
you know the guys that wear the suits
and then I I don't even listen to him
and you know the fact that he drops the
F-bomb every other word I love that
to a lot of the traits that I most
believe in but when you asked it and I
wanted to give a distinct answer I
admire Emmett you know I've always been
on this journey but no question when I
talk about Shaq behind his back in a
positive manner always
um
I talk a lot about his curiosity
I'm I admire his curiosity so much he's
he's spitting it the way he talks about
it he really does text me he's like
what's this
and like that level of inquisitive
nature
everything you know as I got to know him
because we all watched him from afar
um it just clicked so fast to me that
that was a superpower of his
then is in the way that he loves being a
superhero I was like this guy's [ __ ]
curious he's inquisitive and he's humble
right to be that you've got to be humble
and I think I think everybody here if we
remember certain things from today and
this time together leaning more into
curiosity always always puts you into a
very good spot and I think that's why
he's found himself in many different
places and he's been Uber successful in
some some probably not as successful as
he had an ideology for because he had so
many passions music film other things
like but he's always taking at bats out
of curiosity the lack of fear comes
along with that and so that curiosity is
his starting point
and then he's got a lot of great other
attributes but I would say curia the
I've been inspired to quadruple down on
my triple down on curiosity because I
see it in him
thank you cheers can I get one or two
more juice
that's German in case you didn't know
Gary
uh hi guys I'm Maddie from Boston uh
first off I've only met a handful of you
but this community is [ __ ] awesome uh
so thank you for all the fun guys
uh second off
sorry let's calm it down uh second Gary
I would love 10 minutes with you if if I
could at some point we'll lock in for
five right here I can give you five
right here okay because I know I can
bring one of your childhood passions to
a grand scheme let's [ __ ] go all
right Shaq two quick questions one web
uh three space one Health uh so at right
after V friends launched a couple weeks
later you launched your first nft
project on the ethereum um
yes uh platform I was just curious
because I went [ __ ] hard on it but
always been a huge fan of yours is there
anything in the future for that project
or are we like holding basically the
digital version of the Shaq rookie card
I'll let my guy answer that
yeah you know this [ __ ] dude
[Music]
I bet he had released on eternity yeah
clap it up if you have some of those
because I know a lot of you do
and I think I think a lot of you
remember like that
shouldn't I thought
yeah right are you talking about
ethereum the Shaq gives back no the
first one
eternity oh eternity yeah was that that
wasn't the thing the check is back was
the first one
I don't know like I have a bunch of ones
that came like the one that was like
right before the Christmas that you
pumped on the podcast now I have that
one too but there was another one before
that was that an official one or did
somebody just yeah because I saw it on
Instagram with him talking about it
why don't you show the dude with the
blue hat it so that you guys can when
we're hanging for five minutes he'll
come over and let's confirm that
absolutely I'm trying to figure it out
all right thank you uh is it one with
his face on it right
no it's there's like the there was one
that was uh a bid and the winner that
was supposed to have lunch with you and
then there was other tears underneath
that it had like you were in your
Orlando Jersey there was one in your uh
Lakers jersey Heat jersey and they're
all animated oh yeah I show it to him I
think I know what you're talking about
okay yeah
how much health
um CTE
undiagnosed but I know I definitely have
it is it CTE
I'm not sure the concussion thing okay
cool uh
I've been kind of mulling over this idea
for a couple years now about doing
something uh specifically with
Christopher Nowinski and because I think
and it's you got a tiptoe around when
you talk about this stuff I think that
there's
a lot of potential in the use of
psychedelics for brain injuries
and I was wondering if you think that
CTE is predominant in the NBA as it is
in the NFL
and is that something that you would
potentially get involved with in the
future
I probably won't get involved I've not
never had a concussion but I don't I
used to give them
but uh
[Laughter]
never really looked into it he's
responsible for 63 of his specials is
something I'll probably get into
probably not okay cool thank you guys
yes thank you
like it's always go real fast but we're
gonna cut it off after yes I'll make I'm
taking a good look at everyone who's in
line come over here right away we'll try
to make it nice because I feel bad that
you stood we're about to transition to a
little competition Courtney will come
out and explain it I'm going to let you
ask real quick you five can you guys
come to the corner over here and stand
over there I'm gonna give you a little
extra love right away get them go over
there go over there all right yo my man
let's go you five could we go to the
left instead of the right other side
fire away and then we're gonna give Shaq
a lot of love for this really really
appreciate it go ahead my man thank you
thank you thank you so much for for this
and Dr O'Neill thank you so much for
being here and being here
so uh Bernard Cobb uh super nervous
sorry don't worry brother we got you
so I recently was elected as the board
president for Columbia Children's
Theater in Columbia South Carolina and
uh one of the
thanks one of the tasks that uh that's
been put in front of me is is we're
being kicked out of the of the of the
place where we're at so we we partnered
with Brooklyn uh Lakeview Empowerment
Center and they're an amazing
group or organization they helped 15 000
people a year and with underemployment
and unemployment so Shaq I know you do a
lot with philanthropy as well as well as
you Gary
for me
how would you
you know what what question what
questions or how would you
um suggest that I go to the city of West
Columbia to help
um with uh with either getting together
for a project to build a new theater or
not a theater but a but a performance uh
Center for West Columbia
you explain to them your passion
you ask them what they need
and you figure out and you get it done
like I went to this
women's shelter
let's just walk in
what do you need
oh we need some new furniture need some
new TVs what else new beds Mumbo all
right I'll take care of it oh what do
you mean you take her I'll take care of
it
so you you know again you explain them
your passion
so who I am this is what I do what do
you need and how can we get it done see
a lot of times when I ask people what do
they need I know I can get it done right
away no bureaucracy no talk to the mayor
I'm gonna [ __ ] take care of it right
away
so again when I went to this women's
show to new beds new TV new page Brian
Alex jump on it take a few weeks a few
months get it done and just get it done
oh no charity dinners I just you know
pay for the whole thing myself so I'm
sure you'll figure it out I I think for
you it's all storytelling you're gonna
have to compel the people that write the
check from the government from the city
from the state it's all storytelling
whether that's in deck form whether
that's in 45 dinners one by one with the
decision makers whether that's a video
whether that's unlimited social media
content the only way you get things done
I have a present for you you have a
present for me yeah
ladies and gentlemen say hello to
Charles Barkley
don't work
[Laughter]
got him
I love it
oh he lost his [ __ ] mind yeah that's
The Ultimate Gift I'm glad you didn't
die
um I think you've got a story tell right
and so
when you're asking for money from things
with bureaucracy
you could you you're asking for money
from things with bureaucracy okay and
the answer to that is always
storytelling sometimes it's the local
news back in the day picking up the
story and that got it done other times
it was an article in a newspaper that
was also asking someone to do something
we now live in a world of unlimited
cameras where our phones are better than
Hollywood 30 years ago you've got a
story tell and get people to give a [ __ ]
period so so one last thing to the guy
that was over here again I'm new to this
this border director position but it's
it's acting as if and understanding that
it's not a failure right it's it's an
opportunity to learn and change in that
mindset I mean like I said I'm nervous I
said I practice you know talking but
I'll learn so much 100 and I absolutely
appreciate it
let's hear for Shaquille O'Neal
let's get up
[Applause]